so if you think of culture as an
organism right if you think of memes the
way you think of genes right ideas as
things that replicate right then you can
see how those in the counterculture
right those that agitate the sleep of
mankind are kind of cultural mutagens
right on the one hand we require
collaboration and social cohesion and
the one hand conformity is important to
people working together keeping things
in line achieving some kind of growth
and progress and so on and so forth
addressing the needs of a population on
the other hand you have the importance
of nonconformity those that scare there
was that agitate those that skew and
challenge the system right revolutionary
that make us question and rip the fabric
a little bit and allow us to pierce
through allow some light to come in
allow us to gain a different perspective
right the artists the rebels right those
that think different if every
bumper-sticker cliche but you can see
these kinds of people as cultural
mutagens literally mutations in the DNA
of culture that ended up being
biologically useful it made us more
creative that expanded our peacocks
better
our imagination our language our
architecture you know explosions of new
ideas that emerge through the chaos of
the showstoppers of the firecrackers of
the crazies it's important to question
even the things we take for granted it's
important to make spaces for the artists
right we need to create safe havens and
spaces for those who dare to think
differently because at the end of the
day that's the only way to evolve
you